Network first tries to handle the
request by fetching from the network.
If the network requests fails or
times out, it will try to fulfill
the request from the cache.
This is the strategy to use for
basic read-through caching.
It's also good to use for API requests
where you always want the freshest data
when it's available but would rather
have stale data than no data at all.
This method does have its flaws though.
If the user has a intermittent or
slow connection, they'll have
to wait for the network to fail
before they'll get the perfectly
acceptable content from the cache.
This can take an extremely long time and
is a frustrating user experience.
Network first is ideal for
content that is updated frequently and
not part of the app shell.
For example article content, social
media timelines, and game leaderboards.